what I want to do in this video is one
just do a bunch of addition example so
that we really get some good practice
and we really get warmed up with
addition and what I even more want to
show you is that we now have all the
tools we need to really tackle any any
addition problem so let's just get
warmed up with some one digit addition
problems but these are the ones that
always give me a little bit of a
headache let's start with it really it
was relatively straightforward we want
to say two plus four well we know what
that is we don't think we need to draw
the number line at this point but you
can if you need to remember this 2 plus
4 is 6 not too bad
what about 9 plus 3 we saw that in the
last video 9 plus 1 is 10 plus another
one is 11 plus 3 is 12 9 plus 3 is 12
but it's probably not a bad idea it's
good to visualize what's happening here
but it's also not a bad idea to be able
to do these very fast to be able to
memorize at least with the one digit
addition problems end up being let's do
a couple of harder ones 6 plus 7 this
one always I used to find difficult to
remember but 6 plus 7 is 13 6 plus 7 is
13 draw the number lines and the lemons
and limes if you if you don't believe me
6 plus 7 is 13 8 plus 6 or 6 plus 8 is
going to be 14 and let's say it's the
same thing as 7 plus 7 is also going to
be 14 and if you think about it we got
the same number here is there and it
makes sense right
because we took 1 away from 8 but we had
one more than 6 so it's like you just
shifted the 1 from the 8th to the 6
that's why we got the same answer if
that confused you ignore it let's just
do a couple more of these so 8 plus 8 is
16 these are things that hopefully
you'll you'll be able to do superfast
and then not too far off future 5 plus 6
that's 11 these are things let me just
do a couple of more really fast so let's
say 7 plus 9 is going to be 16 you might
want to draw the number line if you
don't believe me and that's going to be
the same thing as 8 plus 8 is also 60
and the nine plus nine is 18 and then
nine plus eight is 70 and that's just a
little bit of warm-up we didn't do all
of the possible combinations of one
digit numbers but these are some of the
ones that give people a little bit more
headache so now that we've done that
let's tackle some larger digit numbers
that we started doing in the previous
video in the previous maybe I'll leave
that there for now so let's do a couple
of them let's do 22 plus 3 22 plus 3 so
we go to the ones place 2 plus 3 is 5
we didn't have to carry anything and
then in the tenths place we just have
this one 2 sitting here so we just take
that 2 2 plus nothing it's two tens it's
two dimes so then we put that down there
so we get 25 two dimes and five pennies
or 25 cents depending a lot of people
money makes it easier to be to
understand things or maybe maybe to be
motivated to understand things all right
let's do another one
what is 38 38 plus 38 plus 17 38 plus 17
so what's so we look at just the ones
place what is eight plus seven well we
haven't done that one yet I'll do it up
here eight plus seven is equal to what's
going to be one more than eight plus six
right 8 plus 6 is 14 then eight plus
seven is going to be one more than that
so it's eight it's going to be equal to
15 so in the in this problem we write
the five here let me write this in a
different color so the five and the 15
we'd write right down there in the ones
place and we would carry the one because
that's one dime that's one ten when you
know when it's one you know this 15 this
is ten plus five so this this one really
means one ten or one time so we put that
one up there in the tens place
and we have one plus three is four plus
one is five so you get 55 one plus three
plus one is this five 38 plus 17 is 55
or five tens and five ones that's
same thing is 55 let's do a couple more
problems I think you'll see that we have
the tools to tackle anything any problem
let's say we have 47 let me switch
colors just to just so it stays
interesting 47 plus 947 plus 9 so we
just look at the ones place 7 plus 9 we
know what that is already we did that
problem already 7 plus 9 is 16 so you're
right the six in the ones place and
carry the 1 and that in now it's in the
tens place right because this is 110
right there
so one tenth one dime plus four dimes is
five dimes so it's five dimes and six
pennies it's 56
let's do slightly harder problems let me
scroll down a little bit so we have some
space to work with space to work with us
we always need that alright let's let's
do this let's do something hard 99 plus
88 that's a hard one all right when you
just have to look at the parts of the
problem and you'll see how it'll all
work out you just say what's what's 9
plus 8 we did that up here 9 Plus 8 we
know already is 17 that's a good one to
remember 9 Plus 8 is 17 it's always good
to be able to visualize it as well so 9
plus 8 is 17 carry the 1 and then we
have 1 plus 9 is 10 10 plus 8 is 18 now
this is interesting we want to write 18
down so we have write our 8 down there
right we have 1 plus 9 plus 8 1 plus 9
plus 8 is equal to 18 we wrote the 8
down there and we say let's carry the 1
we carry the 1 but we carried into the
hundreds place this was the ones place
the tens place now we're in the hundreds
place but there's nothing else in the
hundreds place so it just dropped
straight down so you could almost just
write the 18 just like that so 99 plus
88 is 187 let's keep doing some examples
well you can see that's all the same
pattern we could probably we could add
to 10 digit numbers to each
as long as we're just careful about
carrying our digits so let's do 700 let
me switch colors because I'm will do
some three-digit numbers let's do a
four-digit number let's not mess around
let's do a four-digit number so let's do
four thousand three hundred and sixty
eight plus five hundred and seventy two
let's see what happens here all right
eight plus two I'll write it down here
eight plus two we know that that is
equal to ten you could do the number
line if you need to eight plus two is
equal to ten put the zero in the ones
place carry the one now we're in the
tens place this is really one ten this
is six tens
this is seven ten so you can think of
them as dimes if we're thinking about
change
so one dime plus six times is seven
dimes 7 x plus seven dimes is 14 let me
write it like this we could write 1 plus
6 plus 7 is equal to 1 plus 6 is 7 7
plus 7 is 14 so this right here is going
to be equal to 14 carry the one that we
have let me do it in another color I'll
do it in pink we have 1 plus 3 we're in
the hundreds place now plus five one
plus three plus five well 1 plus 3 is 4
1 plus 3 is 4 plus 5 is 9 4 plus 5 is 9
so this is going to be equal to 9
nothing to carry we only had something
in our ones place 9 is just 9 pennies
it's no dimes it's just 9 pennies and
then we go to the thousands place
nothing to add to the thousands place so
you just take this 4,000 you see a 4
here but since it's in the fourth digit
to the left this means 4,000 so this
4,000 right here we don't have any other
thousands to add it to so we just bring
it straight down so you bring the 4 down
there so four thousand three hundred and
sixty eight plus 572 is four thousand
we'll put a comma there to make it
easier to read four thousand
940